in this video you're going to learn how
to graph the secant graph and the
cosecant graph as well as secant and
cosecant graphs that have been
transformed like stretched or shrunk or
shifted and we're going to do this all
from the perspective of using the table
and the unit circle so let's go through
some examples together and you'll see
how this works so if you've already
learned about the unit circle you know
that on the unit circle the cosine of an
angle we look at the x coordinate of the
point and the sign we look at the y
coordinate of the point on the unit
circle and the tangent we look at the Y
over the X but here in this video we're
talking about the secant and the
cosecant and the secant is the
reciprocal of the x-coordinate or you
could say 1 over X and the cosecant is
the reciprocal of the y coordinate or
you can say 1 over y
so what we can do when we graph our
secant graph let's start with that one
first is we can look at graphing the
cosine graph and we're going to use that
as a template and I'll show you what I
mean so with the cosine at zero degrees
the cosine is going to be equal to 1.
okay and at 90 or pi over 2 the cosine
is going to be equal to zero
and then at Pi or 180 the cosine is
going to be negative 1.
and then at 3 pi over 2 cosine is equal
to 0 and then at 2 pi you're back to one
and so you might want to memorize this
table but you can also get it back from
the unit circle so let's graph that on
our graph here so at zero we're here at
1. at pi over 2 or 90 we're here at 0 at
Pi we're down here at negative one
and then at 3 pi over 2 we're back to
zero and then at 2 pi we are at one and
I'm just going to draw this as a dashed
or kind of like a dotted line here
and you're already familiar with this
cosine graph
but it keeps going so you can kind of do
a little bit more here if you want to
kind of repeat this pattern
but remember that secant is the
reciprocal of cosine or you can say it's
1 over X so what happens here is you see
how where cosine is equal to zero one
divided by zero is what well you can't
divide by zero so that's undefined so
what happens is we get a vertical
asymptote
wherever the cosine is equal to zero and
that in this case is where it crosses
the x-axis right so I'm just drawing
some dashed or dotted lines
for our vertical asymptote
now the other key points are the turning
points or the bends in the cosine graph
so you see right here where it bends or
turns this is where cosine is equal to
one
and what's one divided by 1 well that's
still going to be one so the secant
graph and the cosine graph are going to
coincide at this point
but you see how the graph is kind of
like going down here the cosine graph
and see how cosine is like about a half
right here well what's 1 divided by a
half well when you divide by a fraction
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
right so 1 divided by a half is actually
going to be two so we're going to have a
point up here same thing here if this is
a half this is going to be 2. and you
can see as this gets smaller and smaller
when you divide by a smaller and smaller
number overall that fraction actually
becomes larger like if this is 1 4 1
divided by 1 4 is going to be 4 which
means that you're going to be up here
and so you can see what's happening here
is that this graph is bending like this
okay and then same thing over here the
graph is going to bend the other
direction
like that so you can see that again they
coincide at the Maxes and the mins for
cosine and it bends that opposite
direction so this is what we call our
parent function this is our secant graph
let's talk about the domain and range
for a minute
so the domain is going to be all real
numbers except for where there's these
gaps here where these vertical
asymptotes are so we could say domain
all real numbers but X cannot be
pi over 2
and then we keep adding pi to get to the
next vertical asymptotes we're going to
say x cannot be pi over 2 plus pi n
where n is an element of the set of
integers okay so n is like one two three
the range that's what the Y values can
be and you can see it's going to go from
negative Infinity up to negative one
okay
including negative 1 and then it jumps
up here to positive one and greater so
we're going to say a union from 1 to
positive Infinity
so let's take a look at the cosecant
graph next
okay now taking a look at cosecant we're
going to go to the sine of graph first
to use as a template because remember
sine and cosecant are reciprocals of
each other so on the unit circle we say
that the sine is the y coordinate so at
zero degrees or zero radians the sine is
going to be equal to zero
and then at 90 or pi over 2 the sine is
going to be equal to 1 and then at 180
or Pi the sine is going to be equal to
0. and at 3 pi over 2 or 270 the sine is
equal to negative 1 and then at 2 pi
we've made one complete cycle or one
complete circle here and we're back to
zero for our sign so let's go ahead and
sketch that as a dashed or dotted line
on our graph here we're going to use
that as a template so 0 0 is going to be
right here at the origin and then pi
over 2 1 is going to be right here and
180 0 is back to the x axis 3 pi over 2
is at negative 1 and 2 pi is back to
zero so again just drawing this lightly
to use as a guide
and then remember just like we talked
about previously it with secant whenever
this crosses the x-axis or whenever you
could say that sine is equal to zero
because the cosecant is 1 over y or 1
over the sine 1 divided by 0 is
undefined so that means that we're going
to get a vertical asymptote
wherever you see this sine graph
crossing the x-axis
okay so I'll just draw those in there
and then we also talked about that where
the graph bends that the cosecant and
the sine are going to coincide just like
the cosine and the secant coincided and
then the graph just bends the other
direction and again we've talked about
that because as this gets smaller like
one divided by half would be two or one
divided by 1 4 would be four and so this
actually the cosecant graph is actually
getting larger now here where it's a
negative one-half one divided by
negative one-half is negative two and so
that's why this is bending the other
direction and then keep in mind that
because the sine graph you know
continues forever and ever in both
directions the cosecant graph will also
continue on and on but here what I've
done is just drawn one cycle or one
period so let's talk about the domain
and the range for a moment
remember the domain is going to be all
real numbers
but X cannot be where these gaps are
where these vertical asymptotes are so
it can't be at zero or Pi or two Pi so
it's basically at multiples of Pi so we
could say pi times n
where n is an element of the set of
integers okay that's what that Z
represents and then the range we're
looking at the Y values and again it
looks like you're going from negative
Infinity to negative one
including negative one and then it jumps
up to one
on up to positive infinity and so that's
your range now the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to go through
two problems one cosecant and one secant
graph with Transformations and I'm going
to show you how to work with this table
to get a good sketch of your graph okay
for this first example we're going to
graph y equals 2 secant one half the
quantity x minus pi plus one
so we're going to work with
Transformations but first what we're
going to do is we're going to graph a
cosine graph in this form a cosine b x
minus h plus K and we're going to use
that
to graph our secant graph so remember we
go to our table and we're going to put
in our basic values for cosine and
remember cosine is the x coordinate on
the unit circle so this is going to be
1.
and then to 0 to negative 1 to 0 back to
1. so 1 0 negative one
zero and back to 1.
okay but now we're going to look at the
transformation so imagine instead of
graphing secant we're graphing cosine so
this a value is like a vertical stretch
it's like the amplitude and so what it
does because it's affecting the the Y
values this vertical direction we're
going to multiply all these y values by
2. so that's going to make this 2 0
negative 2 0 and 2 and I'm just going to
cross out those old y values okay now
I'm going to go to the one-half now the
one-half whatever is grouped with the X
okay it's like with the X it has the
opposite effect what I mean by that is
it looks like you're multiplying by one
half you're actually going to be
multiplying the X values or this
horizontal Direction by the reciprocal 2
over 1. so I'm going to multiply all
these X values by 2 this is going to be
pi 2 pi 3 pi and 4 pi and I'm just going
to cross out those old X values
now I'm going to go to this H value now
the H value is going to shift the graph
left and right but again because this
group with the X it has the opposite
effect the minus Pi is actually going to
shift the graph right Pi which means I'm
going to add pi to all the X values
because the X control is left and right
so if I add Pi here this is going to be
pi
2 pi 3 Pi 4 pi and 5 pi and let's just
cross out those old X values and then
lastly we're going to work with this K
value here this 1 and that's going to
shift the graph up one of course
vertical Direction that's affecting the
Y values so we're going to add 1 to the
Y values here so that's going to put us
at 3 1 negative 1 1 and 3 and Let's
cross out those old y values so now we
have our coordinates for our cosine
graph
and so let's go ahead and plot those so
Pi it looks like we're counting by Pi's
on the x axis so I'm just going to label
this Pi 2 pi 3 Pi 4 Pi 5 Pi Etc
negative pi
and this is like one two three okay so
we're plotting Pi 3 so that's going to
put us right here 2 pi we're at 1.
3 Pi we are at negative one so right
here 4 Pi we are at positive 1 and 5 Pi
we're back to 3 right about here so I'm
just going to sketch this
cosine graph
and remember it repeats so then it would
come back down here like so
and this point would be like right over
here okay and it keeps repeating right
but what we're going to think about now
is we're going to think about this
midline you see this midline that kind
of divides that cosine graph in half we
can think of that kind of like our new
x-axis and remember when the secant
graph and the cosine graph remember when
the cosine was zero one over zero was
undefined so where it crosses this like
new x-axis here this midline you can
think of that as like our our x-axis and
our parent function and so that's where
our vertical asymptotes are going to be
so it's going to cross right here
2 pi over here at 4 pi over here at 6 Pi
Etc forever and ever and then now what
we can do is we can graph our secant
graph and remember how the secant
and the cosine they coincide at those
turning points or those places where the
graph bends
and so we can get a good graph so
there's a lot of lines on here but the
dash ones we don't really that's not
really part of our graph we're just
using that as a guide the actual graph
are these
Parabola looking type shapes okay
so now let's talk about the domain in
the range for a minute so the domain
this part can sometimes be tricky for
students
the domain is going to be all real
numbers
okay all reels but X cannot be where
these asymptotes are so we have an
asymptote at zero two Pi 4 Pi 6 Pi you
can see that's multiples of 2 pi so it
can't be 2 pi times n where n is an
element of the set of integers the range
the Y values are going to go from
negative Infinity up to negative one
including negative one and then it picks
up over here at 3 and that goes higher
than that so from 3 on up to positive
Infinity now a question you might have
in your mind right now is Mario
why did you do
this first and then this and then this
and then this is it just because you're
reading from left to right well no when
you learn about Transformations you have
to think about how you're building the
function like if you start with your
parent function
you know that what's the order of
Transformations now you can do this in a
slightly different order you could do
this first
okay and then this second and then this
third and then this fourth or you could
do this first and then this second and
then this third and then this fourth
what I recommend though is that
you do the horizontal
stretch or Shrink first and and then the
shift followed you know after that and
then I always do the vertical shift up
and down last okay that that's going to
always occur last
but just to keep it simple when it's in
this form here you can just basically
work from left to right and you're going
to get the correct um graph let's take a
look at another example involving
cosecant okay for number two we've got y
equals negative cosecant pi over 2 times
the quantity X plus one minus one if
you're getting the hang of this see if
you can try this one on your own and
while you do that
I just wanted to mention that if you
like the way that I explain things and
you want to go deeper with me I've got
an Algebra 2 slash college algebra
course I'll link in the description
below and I go through a typical Algebra
2 college algebra curriculum there's
about 85 lessons in that course and I
take you step by step by step each
concept building on the previous with
teaching examples some practice that you
can do on your own and we'll go through
those together as well so check that out
if you're interested and then if you
just want to support the videos that I'm
putting up here on my Mario's Matthew
YouTube channel I just strongly
encourage you to join as a channel
member so for a few dollars a month you
can support the videos that are being
put up here and I see all the different
names and YouTube handles and channels
and so forth that are supporting the
channel and I really appreciate that so
let's go ahead and finish up this
problem here and what did you get when
you graphed this well what we want to do
because we're graphing the Cosi weekend
is we want to look at the sine graph
because sine and cosecant are
reciprocals of each other and remember
on the unit circle the sign is the Y
coordinates so we're going to be looking
at these y values 0 1 0 negative 1 back
to zero then we're going to look at the
Transformations and again like I
mentioned I like to go and order a b h k
from left to right
this negative 1 is going to reflect it
over the x-axis it's going to make all
the Y values the opposite so I'm going
to multiply all these y values by
negative 1.
and I'm just going to cross out the old
ones
then this pi over 2 is going to be a
it's affecting the horizontal Direction
but whatever is grouped with the X
remember this has like the opposite
factor in this case the reciprocal
effect so instead of multiplying by pi
over 2 we're going to multiply by 2 over
pi to the x value so this is going to be
0.
1 2 3 and 4 cross out those old X values
the plus one again group with the x is
going to affect the X values the
horizontal Direction but it has the
opposite effect the plus one is going to
actually shift everything left one which
means I'm going to subtract 1 from all
of these
X values
and then lastly this minus 1 that's
going to be like a vertical translation
and this is going to shift the graph
down one so I'm going to subtract 1 from
all our y values
cross out the old ones now we have
everything we need to graph our sine
graph which we're going to use as a
template so let's see it looks like
we're counting on the x-axis by ones one
two three four
5 6 negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
and we'll count by ones here on our y
axis
so it looks like we have negative 1
negative one which is like right here
and zero negative two which is right
here
and one negative 1 which is right here
and choose zero which is right here and
3 negative 1 which is right here and of
course it repeats so there would be a
point here and then a point like here
and a point
here and a point here okay so you get
the the just there and so that's our
sine graph right not our we haven't
gotten to our cosecant yet but this is
like our sine graph so that's why I'm
drawing is it a dash or dotted line and
then I like to kind of look at this
midline here okay it kind of divides it
in half like that wherever the sine
graph crosses the midline that's where
our vertical asymptotes are going to be
so there's going to be one right here at
five
there's going to be one right here at 3
. see how it's crossing right here it's
going to be one at one
there's going to be one here at negative
one
it's going to be one over here at
negative three and so on forever and
ever but our actual graph because we
were trying to graph cosecant remember
it's going to coincide at these turning
points where the graph bends and you can
see that that this shaded one this
darker one that I'm drawing that's our
actual graph that's our actual cosecant
graph
domain and range domain all real numbers
right
but X can't be where our asymptotes are
because there's a break in the graph
right there's a a gap so we it can't be
at let's see one three five so it's
basically it can't be one plus
two n where n is an element of the set
of integers and the range
is going to be let's see from negative
Infinity to negative 2
including negative two so we use the
square bracket and then it picks up over
here at zero the positive Infinity so
including 0 to positive Infinity so
great job if you're able to follow these
examples if you want to see more about
graphing these trig functions not just
cosecant and secant but sine cosine
tangent cotangent follow me to that
comprehensive video I did right there
and we'll get some more practice I'll
see over in that video